Angela Merkel is the most astonishing
and successful political survivor in
Germany since reunification
Angela Merkel always want the people
around her, those who work with her to be
very, very loyal, and not to talk to the
media by their own. Whoever breaks this
unwritten law will be thrown out
immediately
It was quite clear, she had to take the decision to throw him out
because she wants to
show her authority towards him
Angela Merkel started in 1990 at the
cabinet of Helmut Kohl.  She was a
very, very good observer; she listened
carefully and she learned a lot
just from observing how Helmut Kohl is
doing politics
when she dared to write the important
letter, an open letter, published in a big
German newspaper, where she said goodbye
to "the old horse" as she wrote, Helmut Kohl
Yeah that was a big strategy but it
came out to be true and it helped
her to achieve the presidency of the
party
she had the feeling that the
demands of society do not really
correspond any more with the program of the CDU.
So she modernized her party in
an extraordinary way
she adapted the program of her party to
the needs of society, and a little less to
the needs of her party.
she keeps calm
and carries on which means she's not
intimidated by anything
Angela Merkel - everybody knows it - is
afraid of dogs
and she was like freezing but
she didn't show her fear and this is very
typical for her, she faces any situation
without showing her emotions or very
very few emotions
German people do have a lot of
confidence in Angela Merkel and one
point why they do have this confidence
is because Angela Merkel is leading a
very very modest, private life so she is
regarded as being incorruptible